hello everyone and welcome to this video
on how to achieve seamless operations
with gke load balancing the content
creators for this video are Aishwarya
Rajiv and Shakil Ahmed Siddiki who are
technical account managers for Google
Cloud Consulting and are specialized in
Google kubernetes engine and networking
in this video we will go over
understanding gke load balancers the
different load balancers that are
supported by gke and how to choose the
right load balancer for your use case in
addition you will gain a deeper
understanding of container native load
balancing
so let's get started to begin with what
is a gke load balancer gke load
balancers are used to distribute traffic
to pods in a kubernetes cluster gke
provides a variety of kubernetes native
constructs like service Ingress Gateway
and network endpoint groups to manage
layer 4 and layer 7 load balancers on
Google Cloud
we will learn more about these
constructs in this video
you can create a gke load balancer
either by using the kubernetes API or
the kubexl command line tool
gke load balancers work by routing
traffic to pods based on a set of rules
these rules can be based on the hostname
path or HTTP method of the requests when
a client sends a request to the load
balancer the load balancer first checks
the routing rules to see which rule
matches the request if a rule matches
the load balancer then routes the
request to the Pod that is associated
with the rule and if no rule matches the
request the load balancer will route the
request to a pod randomly
gke load balancers use a round robin
algorithm to distribute traffic across
the pods that match a rule Additionally
you can also configure gke load
balancers to use different algorithms
like weighted round robin algorithms for
Distributing traffic
to better comprehend we can expose
Services outside a cluster let's define
some terms like node Port service load
balancer service Ingress and Gateway a
node Port is used to expose a service on
each node's specific port
cluster IP is the cluster's internal IP
the load balancer service is useful for
routing traffic between services in the
same network Ingress Gateway creates
https load balancers by using an Ingress
resource however https load balancers
are designed to terminate https requests
and can make better context aware load
balancing decisions they offer features
like customizable URL maps and TLS
termination
gke automatically configures health
checks for https load balancers if you
are exposing an https service hosted on
gke https load balancing is the
recommended method
there are a few challenges when
operating seamless services with gke
however gke is a powerful platform for
running kubernetes clusters
by carefully planning and managing your
gke cluster you could overcome these
challenges and deliver a seamless
experience for your users
let us look at some common load
balancing challenges with gke when
traffic reaches a kubernetes node it is
handled the same way regardless of the
type of load balancer
the load balancer is not aware of which
nodes are running pods for its service
therefore it balances traffic across all
nodes in the cluster even those not
running a relevant pod
on a regional cluster the load is spread
across all nodes in all zones for the
Clusters region when traffic is routed
to a node the node routes the traffic to
a pod which may be running on the same
node or a different node additionally
clusters are dynamic in nature meaning
that pods can be created and destroyed
at any time this can make it difficult
to track which pods are healthy and
available to receive traffic
traffic can also get forwarded to a pod
on a different node this requires extra
Network hops if you want to avoid the
extra hops you can specify that traffic
must go to a pod that is on the same
node that initially received the traffic
throughout this video you'll learn how
to achieve seamless Services over the
network and to minimize or eliminate
traffic disruption
let's now transition to gke supported
load balancers
gke offers diverse load balancing
options through the Ingress and service
API resources these options include
internal or external load balancing
layer 3 layer 4 supporting TCP and UDP
protocol or layer 7 supporting HTTP and
https and Global and Regional scopes
this table Maps gke objects to Google
Cloud load balancers where the gke
resource and gcp resource columns
correspond to each other
the gke resources are used to expose
kubernetes services to the outside world
while the gcp resources are the
underlying load balancers that handle
the traffic additionally let's take a
moment to describe a Gateway class a
Gateway class is a resource that defines
a template for TCP UDP layer 4 load
balancers and https layer 7 load
balancers in a kubernetes cluster gke
provides Gateway classes as cluster
scoped resources cluster operators
specify a Gateway class when creating
gateways in their clusters
hence to summarize gke supports three
types of load balancers layer 4 TCP UDP
pass-through load balancers which
forward traffic to pods within the same
cluster without proxy and processing you
can create it using the service API with
the type load balancer annotation layer
4 TCP UDP proxy load balancers which
forward traffic to pods within the same
cluster with proxy and capabilities for
tasks like SSL termination and header
rewriting it is created using Standalone
Network endpoint groups and an external
load balancer and lastly layer 7 https
proxy load balancers which forward
traffic to pods within the same cluster
with proxyin and https routing
capabilities you can create it using the
Gateway API or the Ingress API
let's now see what a gke load balancer
controller is and how you can use one
for internal load balancing
gke load balancer is at kubernetes
add-on that uses Google Cloud load
balancing to distribute HTTP and https
traffic across pods they are scalable
highly available easy to use add-ons
that integrate with Google Cloud load
balancing
they can be configured via yaml the
controller is composed of two parts the
first part runs in control plane nodes
and watches load balancer services and
Ingress API
the second part runs in the
infrastructure and watches multi-cluster
Ingress and Gateway apis
in order to use this controller enable
the add-on in your gke cluster and then
create an Ingress resource to Define
traffic routing the controller will then
create and manage load balancer
resources
now let us understand the gke Gateway
controller and how it is used for
external load balancing
the Gateway controller is Google's
implementation of the Gateway API for
cloud load balancing similar to the gke
Ingress controller the Gateway
controller watches a kubernetes API for
Gateway API resources and reconciles
Cloud load balancing resources it then
implements the networking Behavior
specified by the Gateway resources
the gke Gateway controller is
essentially an evolution of Ingress
there are two versions of the gke
Gateway controller single cluster
manages single cluster gateways for a
single gke cluster this controller is
generally available
multi-cluster manages multi-cluster
gateways for one or more gke clusters
both Gateway controllers are Google
hosted and monitor the kubernetes API
for gke clusters
unlike the gke Ingress controller the
Gateway controllers are not hosted on
gke control planes or in the user's
project making them more scalable and
robust
finally let's explore gke Ingress which
exposes kubernetes services to the
internet
there are two gke Ingress types
Ingress for external https load
balancers deploys the global external
https load balancer
this internet-facing load balancer is
deployed globally across Google's Edge
Network as a managed and scalable pool
of load balancing resources the second
type Ingress were internal https load
balancers which deploys the internal
https load balancer
these internal https load balancers are
powered by Envoy Proxy Systems outside
of your gke cluster but within your VPC
Network
now here's the big question how do you
choose the right load balancer there are
so many options when choosing which load
balancer service configuration to use
for layer 4 consider the following
aspects first the IP address type which
means whether your load balancer can
have an internal or an external IP
address
next what type and how many nodes does
the load balancer support after you
determine your network architecture
requirements use this decision tree to
determine which load balancer service is
best for your network configuration
to choose a layer 7 load balancer you
must understand the difference between
gke Ingress and Gateway Ingress is a
kubernetes object that provides routing
rules for HTTP and https traffic they
can be used to expose services to the
internet or to the other services within
a cluster and can be configured to use a
variety of Ingress controllers including
the gke Ingress controller a Gateway is
a powerful and flexible kubernetes API
used to Route traffic and they support a
wide range of protocols including HTTP
https TCP and UDP
it can create complex routing
configurations including multi-cluster
routing configurations which allow
traffic to be routed between clusters in
a distributed environment
note that Ingress is a legacy object
that has been superseded by Gateway
although Ingress is still supported in
gke it is recommended that you use
Gateway instead finally after
understanding how to choose the right
load balancers let's briefly discuss
container native load balancers
container native load balancing load
balances directly to pod endpoints in
gke using network endpoint groups which
let the compute engine load balancers
communicate directly with pods traffic
is then distributed directly to the Pod
IPS as opposed to traversing the virtual
machine IPS and Kube proxy networking
currently container native load
balancing is only supported on layer 7
load balancers and is enabled by default
container native load balancing must be
used when exposing Services by using
https externally deploying Ingress with
network endpoint groups is highly
recommended as container native load
balancing allows for fewer Network hops
lower latency and more precise traffic
distribution
it also increases visibility and enables
the use of features such as Cloud CDN
and Cloud armor in addition it increases
visibility all the way to the Pod and
fixes rolling upgrades
this concludes the gke load balancer
overview to learn more about the best
practices for configuring layer 4 and
layer 7 load balancers with gke
click the link in the description below
until then Happy cloud computing
foreign